[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans sa hotte caddie
avec ce matin la présidente de contact
entreprises lucie manuel bonjour bonjour
vous êtes notre invité pour parler
essentiellement des ateliers de la
croissance vertueuse mais l'uci manuel
on va d'abord vous faire réagir à
l'actualité
toute récente ces nouvelles restrictions
dans l'accueil du public dans les
activités socio économiques puisque des
statistiques de la situation sanitaire
étant ce qu'elles sont vous êtes un peu
obligé de vous y plier un au sein du
monde économique martiniquais mais
néanmoins vous demandez à un traitement
un peu particulier spécifique notamment
au niveau des aides qui doivent
accompagner donc ces mesures si j'ai
bien compris
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment un coup dur encore pour les
entreprises martiniquaises notamment
pour celles qui sont dans les secteurs
qui sont concernés et puis cette
stratégie du stop and go pour des chefs
d'entreprise c'est vraiment très très
difficile à gérer et c'est vrai que
compte tenu des spécificités de notre
tissu économique à savoir 90 % de tpe
c'est vrai que il y a lieu de repenser
un accompagnement de ces entreprises
avec par exemple une mesure phare qui
pourra être qu arabe carrément l'abandon
des dettes sociales et fiscales
patronales sur 2020 jusqu'à juin 2021
et puis et puis pour celles qui ont payé
par exemple un crédit d'impôt pour
vraiment accompagne accompagner cette
cette période extrêmement difficile et
qui sera mortifère pour pour certains
acteurs du tissu socio-économique et
puis également l'application stricto
sensu de la loi notamment en ce qui
concerne les délais de paiement à savoir
30 jours parce que vous avez des retours
de terrain qui vous disent que ça n'est
pas fait alors ça c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on travaille depuis
effectivement pas mal de temps
force est de constater effectivement
qu'en martinique où nous sommes vraiment
les mauvais élèves en terme de délais de
paiement donc je pense qu'il ya une
certaine prise de conscience qui se fait
au niveau des donneurs d'ordre mais ça
doit vraiment s'accentuer donc ça c'est
l'état les collectivités locales aussi
les entreprises puissent passer ce cap
et ne pas avoir une trésorerie
complètement anéanti alors on le
rappelle contact entreprises c'est une
structure de essentiellement de
communication donc pour promouvoir
l'image de l'entreprise des
entrepreneurs de la martinique auprès
justement des élus locaux des de l'état
de ses services et plus globalement
auprès de l'opinion publique
et vous aviez entamé il ya sept mois
les ateliers de la croissance vertueuse
c'était même le coup d'envoi il y a
quelques mois de l'année de la
croissance vertueuse à l'orias il ya un
jeu de mots autour de vert la couleur
vert pour l'écologie et vertueuse autour
de l'adjectif justement autour des 2 de
la vertu ou des vertus et donc le
questionnement centrale est-ce que
d'économie verte pourrait constituer une
utopie refondatrice pour la martinique
et et ses entreprises
alors il y a eu en tout quatre ateliers
le le dernier s'est tenu cette semaine
c'était mardi dernier nous allons y
revenir mais globalement sur toute cette
période là de sept mois durant laquelle
vous avez fait une sorte de
brainstorming comme on dit en anglais
vous avez phosphorer avec donc des
consultants spécialisés qu'est ce que
vous en tirer comme enseignement cette
opération juste pour positionner un peu
le contexte c'est une opération qui a
été menée par contact entreprises avec
deux autres associations partenaires que
son entreprise est en mouvement et et
réseau entreprendre martinique et l'idée
effectivement là notre objectif avec
plusieurs événements dont ces quatre
ateliers autour de la croissance
vertueuse était de mettre la réflexion
au coeur du débat public
là cette réflexion autour de la
croissance vertueuse à savoir
les pistes de développement qui lie à
autour de l'économie verte de l'économie
bleus alors c'est vrai que le dernier
atelier a eu lui a eu lieu cette semaine
et que nous allons maintenant entamer le
travail de synthèse vont pouvoir faire
paraître leur livre vert très bien mais
rappelons que le premier atelier donc
qui qui avait eu lieu en septembre je
crois avait consisté dans un premier
temps justement à cartographier liste et
c'est à dire bon planter le décor savoir
de quoi on pas est ce qu'il y à faire
parce que bon est ce que c'est bon tout
ça on est dans la transition écologique
la transition énergétique tout ce que
vous voulez il ya plein de termes pour
désigner ça mais faut savoir de quoi on
parle et vermont va exactement ces
quatre ateliers nous ont permis à la
fois de faire un peu un état des lieux
des acteurs en présence et en même temps
de voir les pistes de progression qu'il
y a alors forcé de constater que c'est
un marché émergent avec toutefois des
acteurs en présence à la fois tant sur
la valorisation et la préservation des
ressources tant sur l'énergie le
photovoltaïque l'éolien temps sur des
activités de recyclage ou de recyclerie
mais également sur tout ce qui est
souveraineté alimentaire donc
agriculture bio etc
donc il y a un il y assure le territoire
beaucoup de volonté et des projets qui
existent déjà dans dans effectivement
l'économie verte et bleue
mais c'est un marché extrêmement
émergents qu'il convient maintenant de
pouvoir effectivement développer et
accompagner
alors justement dans le premier atelier
et puis on va résumer un peu ce qui
s'est fait au second et troisième
atelier pour venir enfin au quatrième
et ce projet de livre que vous voulez
édité le livre donc vers je crois ça
s'appelle quelque chose comme ça on va y
revenir mais vous vouliez mettre en
exergue les freins rencontrés aussi
parce que bon bah ouais on a on a en
fait on a identifié effectivement ce qui
pourrait être des leviers pour ne pas
pour parler positivement ce qui pourrait
être effectivement des leviers d
condition sinequanone de progression
il est important maintenant à l'heure
actuelle pour que ce mr marchés
émergents deviennent plus stables 1 de
densifier la commande publique pour
massifier effectivement ce marché je
pense notamment à des initiatives qui
pourraient être prises de façon plus
générale sur couvrir l'ensemble des
toitures des bâtiments publics avec du
photovoltaïque par exemple ça
permettrait effectivement d'activer la
commande publique et de densifier le
marché local sur ce secteur là il faut
également stabilisés et rendre vraiment
visible la réglementation l'année
dernière le gouvernement à modifier le
tarif de rachat de l'énergie
photovoltaïque
alors ça a été vraiment un coup dur pour
la filière sur notamment sur les
territoires ultramarins puisque ce sont
des marchés émergents qui n'ont pas du
tout la maturité du marché national et
donc à l'époque nous étions battus via
la fedom notamment pour qu'effectivement
les territoires ultramarins soient
exclus de cette mesure
ça n'a pas été le cas mais effectivement
si on veut que l'économie verte et bleue
évoluer et se massifie il est important
d'avoir de la visibilité sur sur la
réglementation pour vous les initiatives
et les facilités
doivent être prises et mises en place
d'abord ou simultanément par les
pouvoirs publics
synergie du public et du privé là dessus
on peut également les avantages ou et un
troisième levier qui a été identifiée
c'est que pour l'amorçage de projet il
faut un accompagnement spécifique parce
que qui dit amorcer des projets dits
effectivement pouvoir avancer des fonds
et ça souvent les porteurs de projets
sur ces petites unités là n'ont pas ces
fonds là donc il faut un accompagnement
spécifique peut-être pour aller un peu
plus loin il ya aussi des questions de
foncier quand on va regarder un petit
peu les activités qui sont à l'heure
actuelle présente sur le territoire en
terme de d'agriculture bio ou de
souveraineté alimentaire il ya
effectivement là il ya une question de
foncier aussi peut-être de rachat de
foncier de mise à disposition de
certains acteurs donc il ya il y a
effectivement alors tout ça on va le
creuser un peu dans notre synthèse du
livre vert mais on a déjà identifié ces
leviers de progression qui sont
effectivement important
d'accord on comprend action publique et
actions privées doivent doivent aller de
concert en quelque sorte et l'inde doit
impulser impulsé l'autre si on si on
comprend bien vous avez aussi organiser
des échanges entre les acteurs
économiques à différents stades de leur
démarche pour justement voir ce qui peut
être amélioré et parce que là il ya une
question si chacun doit pas être dans
son coin
quelque part il faut que ce soit
vraiment tout le tissu économique qui
qui s'y met en même temps exactement on
a à la fois invité des acteurs qui sont
dans ces secteurs de l'économie verte et
bleue et puis on a également invité des
acteurs de l'économie traditionnelle qui
ont inclus dans leur process des
approches vertueuse je pense par exemple
à des process industriels qui vont
utiliser de la biomasse je pense aussi à
des entreprises de services qui ont
couvert leurs toitures de panneaux
photovoltaïques et qui ont investi dans
un parc de voitures électriques
donc c'est à la fois effectivement de
l'économie traditionnelle qui peut aussi
inclure et c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
l'atelier numéro 3 des exemples vertueux
de d'entreprises qui ont fait le choix
de limiter leur impact sur
l'environnement
et ce qui était intéressant aussi dans
ces ateliers vous parliez de rencontre
c'est que on a on a sur ses quatre
ateliers invité une cinquantaine
d'acteurs dont 2,7 de cette économie
verte et bleue et que de ces rencontres
vont être aussi des nouvelles synergies
projet et ça c'était aussi intéressant
puisque comme c'est un marché émergent
il y as peut-être encore à accentuer les
échanges croisés entre ces différents
acteurs
alors il faut terminer donc le quatrième
et dernier atelier a eu lieu cette
semaine on l'a dit cette tenue c'était
mardi 30 30 mars avec eux au moins huit
ou huit ou neuf participants et et vous
avez un site et sur l'attractivité
territoriale comment intégrer justement
cette volonté de passer à l'économie
verte et bleue qui doit être intégré à
dos et une stratégie de marque
territoriale et là vous vous adressez
peut-être aux élus aux politiques à la
ctm qui va être bientôt renouveler
oui-oui ou tout simplement pour dire
qu'effectivement en accompagnant le
développement de l'économie verte et
bleue on va à la fois préserver nos
ressources et donc est donc
effectivement il faut pas oublier que la
martinique est un hotspot de la
biodiversité et que ça c'est un atout
d'attractivité et que plus on va
préserver ses ressources plus on sera
attractif ils vont on va également
pouvoir développer l'emploi en
martinique
et ça c'est aussi une source
d'attractivité donc c'est vrai que en
développant l'économie verte et bleue on
va pouvoir effectivement développer
l'attractivité du territoire
également parce que c'est quelque chose
qui devient tendance à l'international
et que plus on va pouvoir mettre en
avant des exemples vertueux d'économies
plus on sera attractif pour des cibles
captiver des marchés qui sont intéressés
à a effectivement venir sur des
territoires qui ont développé des
démarches démarche vertueuse et je
parlais effectivement d'attractivité en
termes d'emploi il y as on a également
identifié des filières qui ne sont pas
du tout à développer pour l'instant
alors un ou deux exemples je pense par
exemple à la filière hydro
n il y a une enveloppe de 7 milliards
d'euros qui a été mis sur la table au
niveau national il faut que la
martinique ayant capté parce qu'en
développant cette filière ce sera de la
création d'emplois de la création
d'activités et de valeur ajoutée sur le
territoire ça c'est aussi très important
je pense aussi à certaines filières de
recyclage qui n'ont pas du tout été
explorés comme par exemple le
polystyrène qui nous a été effectivement
suggéré durant ces ateliers
et puis il ya effectivement des
opportunités d'attractivité scientifique
avec peut-être aussi la création
d'unités de recherche donc de r&d
notamment sur la sargasse on a sur le
territoire des acteurs qui sont à même
de monter cette unité de recherche avec
des applications médicinales extrêmement
intéressante
donc tout ça doit donner l'édition d'un
petit livre vert
cette année c'est ça 2021 c'est
l'adjectif est d'accord une sorte de
deux méthodes de ces une contribution à
la réflexion sur sur l'économie verte et
bleue on a sorti à contacter
l'entreprise le petit livre bleu le
petit livre orange le petit livre jaune
sur saint-pierre dernièrement le petit
livre gris sur le btp est donc là dans
la droite lignée on va sortir le petit
livre vert donc non normalement qui sera
disponible à partir de mai 2 mai
prochain ah oui c'est ça la voilà qu'en
quelques semaines merci justement voilà
c'est sur cette nouvelle du petit livre
vert de contact entreprises qui devrait
être édité publié au mois de mai que
nous terminons donc cette séquence de
cinq à dix puisque jimmy nous nous le
disons à notre auditrice et nos
auditeurs et durera une petite pause à
partir de demain pour une petite semaine
voilà et donc nous reviendrons donc
début avril
voilà donc bon week-end de pâques à
toutes et à tous et inciter bien sûr à l
écoute de nos programmes merci encore
lucie merci merci bertrand carouge